notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc olivier dussopt bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec snow et ministre
des comptes publics que vous avez pris
la tête de territoire de progresser
l'ailé gauche de la majorité
présidentielle on va en parler dans
quelques instants détention pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour faire des dossards
l'ombre du groupe ebra les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france on
commence olivier dussopt en parlant de
ce plan qui a été annoncé il ya par
emmanuel macron ce plan france 2030 30
milliards d'euros sur cinq ans c'est ce
qu'a annoncé le chef de l'état sur ces
30 milliards combien seront inscrits
dans le budget actuel le budget 2010
serait en train de travailler
actuellement pour décliner les
propositions les engagements du chef de
l'état c'est un plan qui est massif
c'est un plan qui vise à construire des
avantages comparatifs qui vise à
construire des objets développement des
mails qu'il y ait donc l'économie
française en 2030 soit plus forte
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui et connaît
une croissance plus forte mais aussi un
désavantage sur un certain nombre
d'économies et tenir notre rang parmi
l'économie mondiale le président de la
république l'a dit hier soir le plan va
se mettre en place progressivement sur
cinq ans et dès 2022 nous allons engager
entre 3 et 4 milliards d'euros 3,4
milliards
ils sont inscrits dans dj inscrire comme
je l'avais annoncé devant l'assemblée
nationale mais aussi devant la
commission des finances du sénat c'est
3,4 milliards d'euros soit en train de
préciser les montants seront inscrits
par amendement du gouvernement avant la
fin de la première lecture du texte à
l'assemblée nationale en première
lecture qui a commencé avant-hier sur
ces 30 milliards c'est un chiffre qui
est énorme 30 milliards ils sont
investis sous quelle forme c'est 30
milliards ce sera du cash pardon de ne
parler comme ça ce sera des réductions
ce sera des baisses de taxes de 3 3 pour
l'essentiel des subventions des
subventions au développement de filières
des subventions au développement de
nouveaux objets d'innovation des crédits
aussi pour développer directement un
certain nombre de filières il y aura
aussi des attentes sont propres en plus
des 30 milliards pour quelques milliards
d'euros des aides semblent garantis
inscrits en cohérence avec la politique
industrielle que nous menons 2 non
depuis cinq ans 30 milliards le disait
oriana l'instant c'est énorme mais les
objectifs le sont également oui les
objectifs sont importants mais nous
avons fait un choix un choix de réponse
à la crise c'est un chant de réponse
massive parce que de 2017 à 2020 nous
avons redressé les comptes publics est
je le rappelle systématiquement entre
2007 et 2020 ont tenu les engagements
européens nous avons diminué le poids de
la dépense publique par rapport au pib
nous avons pu répondre massivement à la
crise avec des dépenses exceptionnelles
pour sauver l'économie accompagner les
français c'est 70 milliards d'euros de
dépenses en 2020 71 ans en 2021 sans
compter les pertes de recettes c'est
aussi un plan de relance pour 100
milliards d'euros dont 140 qui viennent
de l'europe il faut toujours aussi le
souligner aujourd'hui ce sont 30
milliards d'euros mais sur plusieurs
années et avec des objectifs qui sont
très forts mais des objectifs qui sont
atteignables et s'il souhaitait lier
alors ça ignoble avec 38 versé à cause
de tout cela de tout ce que nous avons
fait le chantre tenable a tâté lien avec
le sont sinon nous aurions mis plus et
c'est d'autant plus atteignable que ce
que nous avons fait face à la crise est
ce que nous faisons avec le plan de
relance nous permet aujourd'hui d'avoir
la croissance économique la plus forte
de la zone euro les prévisions du
gouvernement sont à 6% et avec grenoble
au maire nous avons dit lundi devant
l'assemblée nationale qu'au cours du
débat d'ici la fin de la navette
parlementaire d'ici à la fin de l'examen
du projet de loi de finances nous allons
revoir nos hypothèses pour que cette
croissance en 2021 ne soit pas à 6 mai à
6 25% alors on peut se dire que passer
de 6 à 6 25 ce n'est pas beaucoup c'est
énorme économiquement c'est énorme et
derrière ce sont des emplois c'est de la
croissance et de la recette fiscale pour
l'état parce que ça compte aussi quand
on a un budget équilibré et c'est la
démonstration que nous avons un tissu
productif une économie qui sont restés
très solide pendant toute cette crise
juste un mot puisque vous vous parlez de
ces chiffres de la croissance on va
revenir sur le budget mais puisque vous
en parlez maintenant
bruno le maire vous disais l'annoncé que
la croissance serait revenu à la housse
à 6,25 est ce que ça veut dire que les
chiffres de la dette les chiffres du
déficit seront également modifiées
évidemment dès lors qu'on bien dès lors
qu'on modifie un des paramètres en
l'occurrence la croissance cela a des
conséquences sur le niveau du déficit et
sur le niveau de la dette nous faisons
les choses dans l'ordre faire les choses
dans l'ordre c'est faire les choses
quand on a vraiment toutes les
informations l'insee relève ou les avait
pas de combien sera là dany 7,6 l'insee
a publié de chiffres du chômage pour le
mois de septembre il ya quelques jours
7,6 pour cent nous sommes revenus au
chômage de 2007 c'est un très bon
résultat le meilleur depuis 15 ans nous
travaillons actuellement pour voir
quelles sont les conséquences d'une
modification de la croissance sur la
dette et déficit et nous allons
respecter la loi de respecter la loi
c'est saisir le haut conseil des
finances publiques avant de transmettre
ces chiffres parlement donc je fais les
choses de choses dans l'ordre nos
services mais services travaillent j'ai
évidemment un certain nombre
d'informations mais la loi prévoit que
ces informations sont d'abord donné au
conseil des finances publiques puis aux
parlementaires on va revenir sur tout ça
juste un dernier mot sur le plan france
2030 après on a longuement parlé du
budget il ya un milliard
qui a été annoncé pour le nucléaire
c'est à dire que chef de l'état
réinvesti à nouveau dans cette énergie
nucléaire il a annoncé la mise en oeuvre
de mini centrales d'ici 2011 est-ce que
c'est pas un peu contradictoire avec le
fait d'avoir fermer fessenheim non pas
du tout nous sommes sur des technologies
très différentes très nouvelle avec les
petits réacteurs qu'on appelle smr c'est
un acronyme anglais c'est sans doute
vraiment de logique différente en sur la
taille que sur l'âge pardon pour cette
expression des équipements concernés
nous avons toujours dit que la marche
vers l'énergie renouvelable et donc la
sortie de l'énergie carbone passe par un
mix entre les énergies renouvelables qui
monte en puissance et nucléaire dire
aujourd'hui qu'on peut aller plus vite
vers les énergies renouvelables ce que
tout le monde souhaite c'est évidemment
possible mais dire qu'on peut y aller
plus vite sans avoir ce mix avec le
nucléaire ce n'est pas raisonnable et ça
nous simplement pas juste petite
question justement sur la sémantique on
évoquait d'instance et le mini réacteurs
et quand on regarde la sémantique du
président la république on entend aussi
parler guerre de mini lanceur pour la
conquête de l'espace la reconquête de
l'espace on a quand même l'impression
qu' il faut faire beaucoup avec peu
enfin beaucoup avec peu c'est 30
milliards d'euros je vous le rappelle on
est en concurrence avec des géants si
derek 30 milliards d'euros c'est peu
hier j'entendais l'opposition notamment
le groupe de la france a soumis ce qui
parlait de mesurettes pour les 10
milliards du ségur tout est bon et
puisqu'on en est à tout relativiser
relativisons tout on parle de 30
milliards d'euros qui viennent s'ajouter
un plan de relance de 100 milliards
d'euros donc on peut dire que c'est peu
c'est un effort qui est massif c'est un
effort qui n'a jamais été fait c'est un
effort qui permet la réindustrialisation
du pays parce que j'ai cette conviction
et elle est évidemment partagée par le
gouvernement nous sommes en ligne tous
autour du président de la république que
la politique industrielle est majeur on
peut rêver d'une économie sans
production ça n'existe pas c'est le même
temps le président du redressement
productif c'est oui pour de vrai cette
fois ci avec des résultats certes il
n'était pas pour de vrai ces résultats
pression qui n'était pas le sien auteurs
nous sommes le gouvernement qui a fait
que la france est aujourd'hui le pays le
plus attractif au lancement et le
gouvernement qui a les meilleurs
résultats en matière de croissance
économique c'est à dire françois
hollande entre autres aux québécois qui
aviez qui n'a pas fait pour vous
entretenue monsieur montebourg vous
pensez à monsieur montebourg aussi vous
pouvez m'a menée sur ce terrain là je
parle du président de la rép licques et
ses efforts pour le pays c'est tout ce
qui compte tenu qu'on va parler du
budget puisque vous êtes cette semaine à
l'assemblée nationale qui a donc entamé
ce marathon budgétaire qui va aller
jusqu'en décembre
c'est le dernier budget du quinquennat
et vous avez entendu bien évidemment
l'opposition notamment le droit de dire
que ce budget était trop dépensier pas
assez d'économies pas assez d'efforts
pour réduire la dette et le déficit est
ce que vous assumez finalement d'avoir
fait un budget de campagne
présidentielle pour emmanuel macron ces
deux fois faux c'est d'abord un budget
qui tient les engagements du président
de la république lorsque je propose au
parlement d'augmenter les moyens du
ministère des armées d'un milliard sept
c'est exactement ce qui était prévu
début 2010 8 dans la loi de
programmation pluriannuelle puisque nous
augmentons plus vite encore les moyens
de la justice et aussi ce qui était
prévu nous allons même un peu plus loin
dans la loi de programmation de la
justice lorsque nous tenons le cap sur
l'éducation et sur la transition
écologique c'est ce que nous avons dit
depuis le début du quinquennat donc
c'est d'abord un budget qui tient les
engagements du président de la
république et ensuite c'est faux pour
une autre raison lorsque l'opposition
notamment l'opposition de droite dit que
ce budget un budget dépensier je
l'invite à mieux regarder les chiffres
c'est un budget qui prévoit en 2022 hors
plan de relance il faut le préciser une
évolution de la dépense publique en
volume c'est le terme consacré de 0 8%
aucun des gouvernements de droite comme
de gauche précédemment n'avait tenu ce
cap là donc nous tenons ce cap et 0,8
pour cent c'est un peu technique un peu
barbare c'est ce qui nous a permis de
2017 à 2020 de tenir nos objectifs et
puis la droite la droite parlementaire
la droite à l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui depuis trois jours nous
explique que nous dépensons trop et la
même droite depuis trois jours défend
minute après minute des amendements qui
nous proposent des dépenses
supplémentaires donc il y avait là vous
explique surtout que vous ne faites pas
assez d'économies a passé de majeur de
rang duquel nous explique en permanence
que nous faisons pas assez d'économies
elle nous propose en permanence des
dépenses nouvelles à chacun ses
contradictions il y a une vertu à
l'opposition qu'il s'opposait c'est
beaucoup plus facile que de postes de se
poser beaucoup facile que de proposer
ses produits vie du soft vous parlez
beaucoup du cap 1 ce cap vous avez fixé
pour le quinquennat vous avez fixé sur
la réduction du nombre de fonctionnaires
est ce que il est tenable ce que vous
allez nous serons à la stabilité des
effectifs et
la proposition qui est des fêtes de
réduire les effectifs de l'état de 50000
équivalents temps plein ne sera pas
attentes nous l'avons dit depuis des
mois et même depuis des années pourquoi
la stabilité des effectifs la stabilité
des effectifs parce que depuis le début
du quinquennat il s'est basé certaines
choses dans le pays il ya eu des
mouvements sociaux il ya eu un grand
débat des engagements sur le maintien
des écoles dans les zones rurales une
pris cet engagement pour les hôpitaux
avec le ségur puis avec la crise
sanitaire et lorsque je suis amené à
soutenir à proposer au parlement de
créer des postes au sein de pôle emploi
pour faire face à la crise économique
l'an dernier de créer des postes au sein
du ministère de la santé pour faire face
à la crise l'année dernière lorsque pour
répondre aux besoins de ses claudettes
sécurité des français dont nous créons
10000 postes de gendarmes et policiers
sur le terrain nous on est utile sur des
montants moins importants des chiffres
importants lorsqu'à après le grand débat
national il y a un accent qui émule sur
une formation technique notamment les
bts et que nous valorisons la filière
des bêtes est cela entraîne la création
de 800 postes est-ce que c'est utile
parce que c'est inutile c'est très beau
mais ça veut dire qu'il faut bien cet
objectif vous avez été ministre de la
fonction publique vous voulez si vous
connaissez des sujets non mais pour ce
quinquennat on a compris vous avez
l'envié sa forme il juste pour la
fonction d'étaler y en a 500 9 par
exemple dans ce goût là et non qu'on
nous doive c'est quand même très long
mais pas le prochain quinquennat n'avons
donné ce qu'il faut remettre sur la
table la baisse les objectifs dans ma
phrase nous l'avons dit dix fois qu'elle
50000 ne serait pas atteint dix fois
mais ça avec moi mais est ce que pour le
prochain quinquennat vous dites il faut
revenir à une baisse du nombre de
fonctionnaires ou est ce que vous dites
continue ce que vous me dire la police
la gendarmerie ce cas il faut oublier
complètement cet objectif de baisse du
nombre de fonctionnaires je pense qu'il
faut veiller avant tout parce que les
besoins et de répondre et pour que les
besoins que cela veut dire que le
candidat m'a conseillé les candidats ne
promettra pas de vanille strict de
fonctionnaires vous le serez le présent
de la république décider quand il sera
candidat et ce sur quoi il s'engagera ce
que je dis c'est qu'il faut répondre aux
besoins il ya des besoins dans le
domaine de la santé des besoins dans la
sécurité des besoins pour la formation
il est aussi les ministères dans
lesquels des réorganisations peuvent
être faites et donc je suis toujours sur
la même ligne qui consiste à dire que le
nombre d'agents publics n'est pas un
tabou ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre
chaque fois que nous réalisons des
opérations des réorganisations que nous
gagnons productivité et que nous pouvons
diminuer les effectifs ils sont le
stress
pour les cinq prochaines années là on a
compris que ça serait pas étonné on a
bien compris mais pour les cinq
prochaines années bcm il faut pas mêler
les sentiments vous ne voulez pas
comprendre ce que je dis ensuite je
parlais il ya des besoins du
magazine esquire jeudi que chaque fois
que tous vont moderniser et réaliser des
économies nous pouvons le faire non pas
parce que nous aimons parce que nous
apprécions supprimer tel ou tel poste je
n'oublie pas qu'il ya des hommes et des
femmes des rires mais parce que cela
représente des engagements en terme de
dépense publique là où nous avons besoin
de créer des postes pour le faisons un
peu pragmatique ne fait pas de mal dans
la matière sur la santé promet d'y
appeler de promesses chiffrées pour les
cinq prochaines années c'est ça vous dit
faut plus promesses chiffrées je ne sais
pas si le présent la république
s'engagera sur un sheep ce que je vous
dis c'est que le bon cap c'est la
modernisation et la qualité du service
public dont l'aspect pas sur la campagne
je sais que vous adorez ça mais ça c'est
pour la campagne bien sûr les gens
n'étaient pas en claquant les deux
serveurs ce qui va se passer
vous anticipez aussi fait ça fait partie
de votre rôle d'homme politique
j'imagine sur la sur la santé le fait
que vous réagissiez ce cap c'est aussi
pour répondre à ce grief qui vous était
fier d'avoir poursuivi la réduction des
effectifs dans cette période de crise
sanitaire nous n'avons pas poursuivi la
réduction des effectifs pour la période
de crise sanitaire il ne faut pas dire
cela c'est faux nous avons recruté nous
avons revalorisé la rémunération penser
que le ségur ces 10 milliards d'euros de
revalorisation salariale en 2021 et
c'est un peu plus de 2 milliards en 2022
pour poursuivre cet effort qui fait
c'est la première fois que c'est le cas
penser qu'en matière de dépenses
hospitalières nous sommes avant la crise
de duke au vide sur une moyenne
d'évolution annuelle de 2,4 pendant
qu'un cana précédent était plutôt 1,6
pensez aussi qu'en 2022 alors que nous
sortons la crise sanitaire nous
l'espérons tous nous serons sur une
évolution de la des dépenses
d'assurance-maladie de 2,6 pour cent
c'est plus que la moyenne sans compter
le ségur quand on compte le ségur né à 3
8% et il faut ajouter à cela les 5
milliards que nous avons prévu en cas de
rebond
sanitaires et de besoin pour faire face
à la crise ce sont des moyens que nous
donnons et s'est justifié à l'hôpital
comme personne n'a jamais donné imaginez
aussi que pour la première fois depuis
plus de 15 ans en 2022 aucune économie
tendancielle ne sera demandé aux
hôpitaux publics français chaque année
il y avait des trajectoires d'économie
des moyens en plus mais des trajectoires
d'économie tendanciel pour essayer de
céret telle ou telle dépense ça ne sera
pas le cas et nous avons dit avec
olivier ferrand que les hôpitaux qui
l'année prochaine réaliseront des
économies parce qu'ils vont se
réorganiser parce qu'ils vont gagner en
efficience garderont le bénéfice des
économies c'est une première aussi donc
on peut dire ce que l'on est en
désaccord avec la politique du
gouvernement dire que nous sommes le
gouvernement qui ne fait pas assez ou
qui fait moins que les autres ça c'est
totalement faux nous gouvernons qui fait
le plus aujourd'hui pour les hôpitaux à
partir de de vendredi les tests ne
seront plus gratuit pour les personnes
qui ne sont pas vaccinés combien ça a
coûté au budget de l'état la gratuité de
cette espèce a coûté très cher sa
coéquipière entre l'année 2020 le début
des tests pcr est ce que nous faisons en
2021 nous serons autour de 8 milliards
dont juste pour les tests lui milliards
d'euros pour les tests et il faut
ajouter 5 milliards d'euros pour la
vaccination première et deuxième dose
mais 8 milliards d'euros pour les tests
2 milliards 8 pour l'année 2020 et entre
cinq et demi et six milliards d'euros
pour l'année 2000 21 selon nos
provisions nos prévisions c'est
extrêmement coûteux c'était utile parce
que c'est une politique de détection
parce que nous sommes un des seuls pays
en europe à voir garantit la gratuité
des tests pcr aujourd'hui nous sommes
dans une situation où celles et ceux qui
veulent être vaccinées peuvent l'être et
facilement et donc celles et ceux qui ne
le souhaite pas et qui souhaitent
utiliser les tests père comme pas
sanitaires doivent aussi en assumer la
responsabilité ce père et combien
d'économie avec sept majeur de non
gratuité des textes évidemment prévue en
2022 pour financer les tests qui
resteront prise en charge les tests sur
prescription médicale les tests pour les
mineurs les tests pour les personnes
vaccinées nous avons prévu un budget en
2022 d'un milliard 6 1 milliards c'est
juste pour les tests et le reste c'est
pour osciller troisième dossier l'aller
5-1 dernier mot vous nous parler du
conseil des finances publiques tout à
l'heure vous ne venez pas vous ne voulez
pas nous révéler le chef de la dette et
du déficit puisque vous allez ressaisir
des finances publiques il y avait jugé
ce budget est incomplète donc on imagine
que c'est pour ça que vous représentez à
nouveau les choses devant le conseil ça
sera quand ça sera pour la présentation
du projet de loi de finances
rectificatif
ce projet de loi de finances
rectificatif est prévue pour le début du
mois de novembre et donc il ya des
délais avant pour que le conseil le haut
conseil soient saisis ainsi que le
conseil d'état on va parler d'un sujet
qui inquiète évidemment les france en ce
moment c'est la hausse des prix de
l'énergie olivier du souk la commission
européenne elle présente ce matin ses
propositions pour réduire l'impact
social de la de la flambée des prix de
l'énergie et bruxelles va notamment
inciter les états à baisser les lourdes
taxes sur l'énergie est ce que vous
allez le faire tout ce que nous faisons
tout ce que nous faisons le bouclier
tarifaires annoncées par le premier
ministre reprend répond à cela jusqu'en
avril le groupement est ce qu'une avons
répondu à la crise
baisse des taxes uniquement sur
l'électricité points vous n'avez pas
regardé tous les amendements que nous
avons déposés je crois comment est-ce
que nous avons répondu cette question
d'énergie d'abord en anticipant et
l'anticipation celle annonce il ya
plusieurs semaines du versement d'un
chèque énergie supplémentaire de 100
euros ménages éligibles nous avons
presque 6 millions de ménages en france
qui sont éligibles chèque énergie qui
ont perçu en moyenne 150 euros en mars
2021 qu'ils vont percevoir 100 euros à
titre exceptionnel dans les jours qui
viennent et qui percevront en moyenne
150 euros en mars 2022 et puis par
exemple et jean castex d'ailleurs juste
sur ce chèque énergie a ouvert la porte
à une nouvelle revalorisation et si
besoin ça veut dire que c'est des gt ça
pas encore puisque le chèque énergie
pour 2021 ce chèque énergie
exceptionnelle nous allons le financer
sur le buzz finances rectificative de
fins de gestion que j'évoquais il ya un
instant par ailleurs il faut maîtriser
l'évolution des tarifs ce qu'a proposé
le premier ministre se résume en deux
points d'abord le fait de bloquer les
tarifs du gaz et bloquer les tarifs du
gaz ça passe par une modification des
droits d'accise c'est un peu compliqué
mais il existait la fiscalité et c'est
encadrer l'évolution du tarif de
l'électricité en jouant sur le niveau de
la taxe intérieure de consommation
finale d'énergie c'est aussi la
fiscalité c'est un dispositif qui est
mis en place qui est prévue aujourd'hui
d'un point de vue budgétaire pour aller
jusqu'au printemps parce que nous
espérons qu'au printemps les cours de
l'énergie puisse être orientés à la
baisse il faut rappeler tout ça vient
d'une augmentation du prix l'énergie un
niveau mondial et comme l'a dit le
premier ministre si le phénomène devait
durer le dispositif pourra être
prolongée parce que le dispositif que
nous votons permettra d'aller plus loin
en cas de besoin c'est pas un peu votre
talon d'achille cette question de
l'énergie aie qui concerne tous les
français acceptait talon d'achille de
tous les pays européens que les pays
mondiaux nommé pour vous en particulier
miniser comptes publics qui doivent la
rentrée de l'argent et qu'ils en
parlaient de réserver
ému environnement les mesures que nous
prenons sont des pertes de recettes pour
l'état des pertes de recettes pour
l'état qui se traduisent par une
protection du pouvoir d'achat des
français mais quand je dis que c'est le
talon d'achille de tous les pays
européens et tous les pays mondiaux
c'est pour souligner que cette hausse du
prix l'énergie elle n'est pas française
elle est mondiale elle est mondiale et
vous avez un très grand nombre de pays
pour ne pas dire la quasi totalité des
pays qui laisse les consommateurs
assumer ou en tout cas faire face à la
totalité de la hausse nous agissons à la
fois en ville en direction des presque 6
millions de ménages les moins favorisés
par ce chèque énergie spéciale de 200
euros et nous agissons par la fiscalité
pour faire en sorte de bloquer cette
évolution du tarif de l'électricité du
gaz pendant l'hiver pas encore sur la
tva bruxelles va également donner ce
matin la possibilité aux états de
baisser la tva pourrait aider à les
regarder est-ce que vous allez le faire
nous allons regarder ce que propose la
commission européenne nous allons aussi
voir comment elle propose à dire qu'elle
ne permet pas la porte à une baisse de
la tva sion il n'ya au par définition il
n'y a jamais eu aucune porte fermée ce
que nous regardons sait comment être le
plus efficaces et les dispositifs que
nous avons retenus sont ceux que je
viens de décrire à la fois sur la tsf
pardon pour l'acronyme et sur les droits
d'accise qui concerne le gaz et ces deux
dispositifs font l'objet d'amendements
déposés devant l'assemblée nationale
pour qu'il puisse être adopté dans le
cadre de la loi de finances l'autre
problème c'est la hausse des prix à la
pompe et à la hausse des prix du
carburant puisque là vous passez vous
parlez de baisses de taxes à une dalle
web propose le pca les taxes sur le
carburant c'est une bonne idée pour vous
je me rappelle d'un hidalgo en 2018 qui
expliquait qu'il fallait une fiscalité
sur les énergies carbone pour sortir du
carbone c'était en 2018 fin 2018 et
aujourd'hui il explique au gouvernement
qu'il faut baisser les taxes sur
l'énergie carbone vous pensez que c'est
opportuniste n'est pas la première
contradiction gspc opportuniste mais en
tout cas c'est une contradiction pour
aider les français qu'il a actuellement
fond
face à une vraie hausse des prix à la
pompe un clip et leur plein beaucoup
plus cher va voir a compilé elle en
appelle aux distributeurs est ce que ça
va être la seule réponse de l'état dont
seulement nous continuons à travailler
sur ce sujet là pour voir comment
accompagner les français mais il est
trop tôt pour dire comment nous pouvons
mais ça veut dire qu'il y aura des
mesures dead je vous dis qu'on travaille
pour le moment et que à ce stade il est
encore trop tôt pour me prononcer mais
vous dites est ce qu'il ya une fatalité
sk une fatalité a payé le fait que les
enjeux jour plus cher je crains que les
énergies carbone et tendance à être
effectivement plus cher et ça m'amène à
une observation c'est que au delà de la
réponse à très court terme une réponse
pour répondre à la conjoncture
économique il faut aussi qu'on pousse
les feux sur ce que nous faisons matière
transition transition bien plus
d'énergies renouvelables développement
de nouvelles d'une nouvelle énergie
nucléaire comme le président lalanne
c'est d'ailleurs parce que derrière
derrière cela il a sorti du carbone dans
la maîtrise des coûts il ya aussi la
reconquête d'une souveraineté
énergétique il ya plein plein de levier
qui peuvent être actionnés hier j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire à l'assemblée le
fait que nous ayons france une filière
sur les biocarburants est quelque chose
de tout à fait majeur et nous avons une
trajectoire pour permettre
l'incorporation des biocarburants dans
les carburants conventionnels aussi vite
que possible parce que les biocarburants
c'est aussi une source d'économie et
souveraineté derniers mois on va parler
de politique vous avez pris la tête de
territoire de progresser l aile gauche
de la majorité puisque on parler d'agos
vous l'avez sans doute entendu anne
hidalgo elle appelle les ministres de
gauche du gouvernement à la rejoindre en
disant je schématise comme vous devez
vous sentir mal dans cette majorité est
ce que vous répondez à cette attaque
pour non merci non mais vraiment non
merci moi je suis très à l'aise avec ce
que je fais d'abord très heureux de
pouvoir animer territoire de progrès
avec un grand nombre de mes collègues
pensent à florence parly à jean yves le
drian emmanuelle wargon est très heureux
de participer à l'unité de la majorité
et à son élargissement autour du
président de la république mais je sais
aussi ce que nous avons fait pendant ce
quinquennat est ce que nous avons fait
c'est le reste à charge 0 pour les
lunettes pour les oeufs pour les
prothèses auditives pour les prothèses
dentaires parce que je sais de
conviction que pouvoir sourire sans se
poser de questions pouvoir entendre ses
petits-enfants c'est aussi un droit
essentiel ils ont fait la cinquième
branche nous avons dédoubler les classes
nous avons augmenté les minima sociaux
augmenter la prime d'activités dont on
fait le ségur avec une revalorisation
des personnels de santé comme cela
n'avait jamais été fait auparavant la
gauche qui réforme la gauche qui créent
des droits j'ai oublié de citer la pma
c'est sa saison les mesures de gauche on
a compris vous avez aussi deux premiers
ministres de droite ya par exemple la
suppression isf ya la réforme de
l'assurance chômage est ce que vous vous
sentez toujours à l'aise je me sens très
à l'aise avec tout ce que nous faisons
absolument tout est dans les exemples
que vous citez je n'oublie pas que
beaucoup vient la suite de mesures qui
ont été adoptées dans le quinquennat
précédent ce qui me laisse penser
parfois que certains dirigeants du parti
socialiste utilise le droit d'inventaire
pour justifier une forme de nouveau maul
et isme mais vraiment la gauche qui
travaillent celles qui créent des droits
celle qui protège les français et elle
est au gouvernement et de bien au groupe
un dernier mot juste sur territoire de
progrès edouard philippe qui a créé son
parti au même moment où vous avez été
élu à la tête de territoire de progrès
il est clair il dit moi je fais pas un
club je fais un parti je veux des élus
je veux des militants vous quel est
votre objectif à 14 octobre est ce que
par exemple vous aurez des candidats aux
législatives sous la bannière territoire
d'un état partie c'est un parti qui
participent à la majorité présidentielle
qui participe à son élargissement et à
son unité et je pense de manière
générale pour nous comme pour les autres
que la priorité des priorités c'est la
réélection du président de la république
dès lors qu'il sera candidat la seconde
priorité ça glisse pour vous comme étant
fihri bouzid cet acquis jeu une élection
n'est jamais acquise par définition il
faut toujours travailler bouger jibril a
duré j'ai confiance je souhaite sa
candidature je souhaite sa réélection et
ensuite il faudra une majorité au
parlement pour le président la
république il faudra que sur chaque sa
conception il y à un seul candidat de la
majorité présidentielle
c'est ce travail d'unité qui me
préoccupe avec les avec edouard philippe
notamment vous dialoguez avec votre
ancien premier avec tous les membres de
la majorité avec un seul objectif
l'unité et la réélection du président de
la république mais ça veut dire qu'il y
aura des circonscriptions avec mes
candidats terrible à vous êtes vous êtes
dans les histoires de boutique avant les
politiques mais sans intérêt mais si ça
n'est pas grave c'est ça fait partie du
débat ce que je dis est ce que je répète
c'est moi je n'ai qu'un seul montre
assez l'unité merci pour merci merci
d'avoir été notre invité ce matin bien
[Musique]